[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
il nous fascine nous attendrissent il
nous subjugue nous épate il nous sublime
de temps à autre nous apaise souvent ils
sont parfois d'improbables compagnon
certains ont choisi d'en faire leur
partenaire de vie
[Musique]
sexton 10 ans partage son quotidien avec
un animal de compagnie quelque peu
particulier alors là ces consignes c'est
une biche qui a été imprégné
imprégné ça veut dire qu on l'a élevé à
la main c'est donner le biberon enfin
faire tout ce que la mère devrait faire
une biche ça reste un animal sauvage
mais
parfois quand on les imprègne comme ça
elles peuvent être très très gentille
copine est une biche de nos forêts de
race et l'afld le plus grand des
cervidés d'or en a pleins ils disent moi
j'ai trois chiens au moi j'ai deux chats
et et moi je dis vaches et des biches
dessert d'eséka dédain et de côté
copine à 17 ans c'est la doyenne d'un
espace qui regroupe plusieurs armes de
cervidés sur 18 hectares une sorte de
sanctuaire pour la préservation des
espèces un parc créé par edmond pour ses
deux filles sixtine et isaure une
expérience de vie unique accumulés au
fil des ans
[Musique]
vient de naître un faon labiche à
accepter isaure le liquide amniotique
qui est sur le fond s'est retrouvée sur
les mains et sur l'un père de notre
fille et la biche a fait la toilette des
deux en pleine nature ça c'est d'abord
ça ne se voit pas et si ça avait été le
cas la biche aurait chargé et boxer
l'enfant ça c'est le top dans la foulée
isaure a essayé de tété à son tour là
j'ai dit stop même si on est en
confiance parce qu'il suffisait d'un
coup de patte qui aurait pu être
dramatique
isaure l'aîné de sixteen alors moins de
trois ans fusionnelle les
expérimentations se succèdent instant
magique elle apprend même à nager avec
copine je pense pas qu'on puisse faire
plus de choses actuelles dans ce type
d'expérience rien n'a été forcée tout
s'est fait naturellement c'est une
adaptation et une adéquation de ce fonds
les animaux avec ce qu'on a pu découvrir
ces c'est une parfaite harmonie entre
l'enfant et l'animal
[Musique]
michel est lui un ancien parisien en
plus il est revenu s'installer à
beaumont villages à l'est
c'est là qu'il a fait une étonnante
rencontre
allait bien voir les miens sur cannes
voici un myocastors
et mignot alors voilà un rat tybus mon
gros bébé d'un ragondin l'état doha bhl
bon après la des grandes dents mais
c'est pas mon ultime union
originaire d'amérique du sud le ragondin
est un rongeur herbivore sans parenté
avec son supposé cousin le castor ils
peuplent désormais nos campagnes je
voulais faire une expérience quand même
avec le ragondin qui est quand même
qu'un mauvaise réputation et en fin de
compte c'est un animal qui est très très
gentil c'est pas du tout un tas minimale
méchant par défaut on peut avoir comme
une relation assez sympa avec lui
20 mo pépère le cri est très fort donc
on a toujours peur qu'ils s'assoient
quelque chose de violent mais enfin
quand c'est juste pour dire qu'il n'est
pas content
invité au t1
donc ça sera un ragondin sauvage je
pense que je me serais fait mordre mais
lui même ne mord pas j'ai de la chance
semi-aquatique cette espèce méconnu et
pourtant surprenante elle revêt des
tranches particularité ça ne produit pas
de salive le ragondin donc il va
mouiller immiscé animaux pour les manger
et ce n'est pas là sa seule singularité
les tétines de la mer sont sur le dos
sur les flancs exactement comme ça les
bébés peuvent tu étais quand ils sont
dans l'eau directement sur la mer ils
ont pas besoin de se mettre dessous
[Musique]
voilà maintenant deux ans que rapibus
partage le quotidien de michel une
rencontre inconcevable à l'origine donc
ce cette pièce d'où je me suis aperçu
qu'il y avait des ragondins donc
commencer cette année nuisibles qui
détruit bâle héberge on a la preuve là
bas on a un trou a été creusé et là bas
j'ai découvert une petite famille de
cette ragondins que j'ai capturé les
ennemis dans une cage et là j'en ai pris
un qui était plus sympa je les gardais
et basse est devenu ratib us c'est le
début d'une belle aventure avec créative
husky bas qui est maintenant un peu la
mascotte de la ferme pédagogique
aujourd'hui michel partage sa passion
des animaux avec le public à travers les
quelques 300 animaux qui composent son
parc zoologique
allait bien tam tout allait bien dans
l'âme que tout allait bien la belle
lalalalalala allait bien
et animalière une professionnelle de
l'imprégnation c'est bien ma belle c'est
un outil prédilection le talkie walkie
plutôt efficace avec cette jeune renarde
moi c'est pour avoir un point de repère
pour que quoi qu'il arrive même si je
suis enrhumé elles reconnaissent bien ce
bruit là d'un aspirateur en fait c'est
une petite renarde qui est née chennouf
alors une petite particularité
accouchement c'est que elle est née au
moment du confinement du coup j'ai fait
du télétravail à la maison j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir la garder à la maison
pendant plus de deux mois et demi et
donc ce qui est sympa aussi c'est
qu'elle est née avec le 24 heures
d'intervalle avec des chiots et donc
elle s'était retrouvée dans le panier
avec la mer rélations donc sacré
vraiment des liens on est devenu
vraiment proche
avec charlie juliette dresse toutes
sortes d'animaux pour le cinéma les
documentaires animaliers ou la publicité
or voilà sixtine au volant de la voiture
est dès qu'elle le peut elle participe
au nourrissage des cervidés ici une
harde de temps
[Musique]
les terrines parce que les animaux c'est
et il
ce qui me plaît c'est de les voir en
bonne santé
de voir que tout va bien
[Musique]
passionné et non poursuit la
transmission ses propres parents avaient
créé le premier parc zoologique privé en
france en 1961 au coeur de la sologne
voici un troupeau de cercy qu'à une
espèce originaire du japon c'est un réel
bonheur que de les voir naître grandir
et quand tu auras les naissances mois de
juin juillet elles seront complètement
mouchetés avec un poil luisant ça
partira de l'encolure jusqu'à la croupe
et on sait à 48 heures près quand est ce
que le petit va naître quand est ce que
la femelle va s'isoler pour le faire ou
comment c'est c'est une partition de
musique qui se répètent tous les ans
même période
[Musique]
ces animaux ont même servi à la
sauvegarde et au repeuplement des
populations asiatiques
edmond a fourni plusieurs femelles à
l'inra et au muséum d'histoire naturelle
un sens supplémentaire à l'action qu'il
a entreprise depuis tant d'années
cc c'est très personnel c'est très
intime j'appelle ça à l'école des biches
parce qu'elles nous ont appris beaucoup
de choses c'est certain on a des mômes
qui ont appris la patience qui ont
appris le sens de l'observation
l'engagement les cycles de la vie du du
brame à la naissance à la mort on a tous
déclinés on a ouvert toutes les fenêtres
c'est bon c'est bon
biberons en main elle a menti black
michel attaque sa journée à la ferme
pédagogique
allez mon gros cochon
doucement
là c'est les blacks un petit cochon nain
que je suis obligé d'élever au biberon
parce que là moment là n'a pas voulu
donc voilà donc cela c'est trois fois
par jour mais au début c'était six fois
par jour look ni comprise comme un bébé
avec nombre d'animaux michel a noué une
relation surprenante quasi fusionnelle
entre eux même nuit je suis nettoyer
tout le temps donc ça c'est des fûts tic
tac toc
assas et toc c'est le dernier qui arrive
et furets albinos c'est vraiment un
plaisir de les manipuler ils sont pas
mort de rien du tout une forme
d'épanouissement réciproque un plein de
sérénité d'être bien avec eux eux sont
bien avec moi parce que quand je suis
bien avec eux voient la juncasse apporte
du plaisir voilà la de l'amour pour ces
petites bébêtes 1 voilà
[Musique]
entouré entre autres des me dewaele
habits ou de la mare michel se nourrit
de ce quotidien auprès de ces animaux
l'ancien responsable informatique d'un
laboratoire pharmaceutique a élaboré une
vie à sa mesure j'ai commencé à
travailler en région parisienne pendant
36 ans et après un burn-out je me suis
réfugié parmi mes animaux en créant la
ferme pédagogique qui me permet d'être
avec mes animaux tous les jours on est
toujours bien avec eux donc c'est vrai
que ben voilà c'est une vie un peu
particulière mais que j'affectionne tout
particulièrement
loin du monde urbain michel partage
désormais sa passion avec le plus grand
nombre
moi j'ai dit voilà bien quand on parlait
à les inquiéter comme juliette charlie a
lui aussi un invraisemblable compagnon
mais là il s'agit de rodolphe un goéland
argenté et rodolphe
ouais c'est bien très bien il est très
bavard et il est très peu de colle aussi
donc ça c'est bien il ya une complicité
entre entre lui et moi il ya un côté
fusionnelle là par exemple
j'ai pas j'ai pas nourriture et il est
quand même voilà il reste quand même à
côté de moi une réussite
et il discute
c'est bien saint tite et patience écoute
persévérance font partie des principales
qualités d'un animal y regarder le
paysage
oui mais chez lui par tout allait bien
tout on est chez nous il est chez lui
c'est paul qui a fondé les animaux du
film il n'y a plus de 40 en france mais
partagent aujourd'hui ses vastes
connaissances animalière à commencer par
le la russe argenta tus traits communs
sur nos côtes le goéland le gone argenté
et est vraiment le seigneur du vent il
sait exactement
comment se comparent pleuvant la
direction en fonction du relief du seul
des roches et cetera on sait les oiseaux
qui volent pour se nourrir
n'est pas ce que je suis absolument
persuadé qu'ils veulent aussi pour le
plaisir
[Musique]
professionnels ou amateurs tous ces
passionnés détiennent des certificats
officiels de capacités indispensable
pour s'adonner à leurs pratiques de
prédilection et juliette et charly sont
des animaliers depuis l'enfance on
devient pas née mallié on et animaliers
voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'on arrive à
voir ces relations absolument excellente
avec les animaux en fait je dirais c'est
un peu les animaux qui nous dresse parce
qu'on est obligé de faire avec leur
fonctionnement donc nos animaux nos
quelques animaux captifs sont sur les
ambassadeurs de leurs congénères
sauvages pour finir et ça vient
complètement justifié notre travail
un engagement de chacun au service du
maintien de la biodiversité